[Applause]  okay so this one more audio we can't  really see oh there goes the guy  and then he gets knocked down and then  just doesn't uh nothing exactly really  happens people very agitated police  getting involved you can really see them  run out there i mean it's pretty if  you're if you're only listening i  encourage you to check out these videos  and then lastly this is the best angle  but it is very blurry we see it actually  from the side and you see the guy run  straight in and then all hell breaks  loose  [Music]  and then police getting involved as well  so what's your thought on this you know  i i've been very clear over the years  lewis and i still stick to this that i  never advocate physical violence period  at the same time it's hard to really  care too much about a westboro baptist  church member getting tackled for  protesting with god hates [ __ ] at a  lesbian soldier's funeral